Das, was ein niederländisches Forschungsteam
jetzt herausgefunden hat, widerspricht wirklich
allen Regeln der Physik!
Und es hat zur Folge, dass unsere globalen
Klimamodelle grundlegend überarbeitet werden
müssen!
Konkret geht es um gigantische Staubpartikel,
die sehr weite Strecken zurücklegen.
Die Fachleute stehen vor einem riesigen Rätsel!
Ihre Beobachtungen basieren wohl auf Prozessen
in der Atmosphäre, die uns noch gänzlich
unbekannt sind.
Alles, was ihr zu diesem mysteriösen Staub-Phänomen
wissen müsst, erfahrt ihr jetzt bei Clixoom
Science & Fiction.
Hier gibt es täglich spannende Wissenschafts-Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann und nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts.
Herzlich willkommen!
Für Klimaforscherinnen und Klimaforscher
ist die Größe der Partikel in unserer Atmosphäre
von entscheidender Bedeutung.
Denn die Fachleute gehen bei ihren Modellen
davon aus, dass Partikel erst ab einem gewissen
Durchmesser Einfluss auf das Klima unserer
Erde nehmen.
Denn die Partikel-Größe entscheidet maßgeblich
darüber, wie weit diese beispielsweise durch
Winde transportiert werden können.
In diesem Kontext nahmen Forschungsteams weltweit
an, dass lediglich Partikel, die kleiner als
10 Mikrometer sind, überhaupt Folgen für
die Klimabedingungen haben könnten.
Ein Teilchen-Durchmesser ab etwa 20 Mikrometer
dagegen sei zu groß für deren Transport
in der Luft über lange Strecken.
Auf Grundlage dieser Annahme werden Partikel
mit einem größeren Durchmesser derzeit nicht
in die aktuellen Klima-Modelle und Berechnungen
mit einbezogen.
Ein Irrtum, der weitreichende Folgen haben
könnte, wie sich jetzt herausstellte.
Ein niederländisches Forschungsteam nämlich
stieß bei Untersuchungen auf verhältnismäßig
große Staubpartikel, die mit Hilfe von Winden
eine äußerst lange Strecke von 3.500 Kilometer
zurückgelegt haben müssen.
Konkret handelte es sich dabei um Teilchen,
die die Fachleute unter anderem von Bojen
aus dem Atlantischen Ozean im Zeitraum zwischen
2013 und 2016 entnommen hatten.
Sie haben den Analysen zufolge tatsächlich
den etwa 3.500 km langen Weg aus der Sahara-Wüste
zurückgelegt.
In diesen Proben enthalten waren gigantisch
große Partikel mit einer Größe von 450
Mikrometern.
Dazu Giles Harrison, der an der Studie beteiligt
war: “Die bislang bekannten Prinzipien schließen
eigentlich aus, dass solch massive Teilchen
in der Atmosphäre so weit transportiert werden
können.
Das lässt uns also vermuten, dass es einen
bisher unbekannten Atmosphären-Prozess oder
eine Kombination mehrerer Prozesse gibt, die
sie in der Luft halten.”
Zu klären ist also jetzt, durch welche Kräfte
und Bewegungen in der Atmosphäre dazu fähig
sind, auch Partikel einer solchen Größe
solch lange Strecken zu transportieren.
Physikalisch gesehen ist das ein riesiges
Rätsel.
Dazu Michele van der Does, der auch an der
Studie beteiligt war: “Die Tatsache, dass
größere Staubpartikel für solch eine lange
Zeit in der Atmosphäre schweben, steht im
Widerspruch zu den physikalischen Gesetzen
der Schwerkraft.”
Ein Ergebnis, das bedeutende Folgen für die
Klimaforschung haben könnte.
Denn klar ist: Partikel in der Luft haben
großen Einfluss auf die Bildung von Wolken.
Und nicht nur das: Laut dem niederländischen
Forschungsteams sind Partikel mit einer solch
gigantischen Größe auch in der Lage, die
Bildung von tropischen Wirbelstürmen zu beeinflussen
zumindest indirekt Dazu heißt es in der Studie:
“Der Beweis, dass diese Partikel so weit
transportiert werden können, ist bedeutsam,
weil sie den Strahlungstransport um die Erde
und die Kohlenstoffkreisläufe in den Ozeanen
beeinflussen.”
Heißt also im Klartext: Globale Klimamodelle
müssen auf der Basis dieser neuen Erkenntnisse
grundlegend überarbeitet werden.
Das könnte auch das bisherige Verständnis
zum Klimawandel verändern.
Klar ist, dass die steigenden Temperaturen
exakt mit den Menschengemachten Klimagasen
korrelieren.
Das heißt, die Temperaturen steigen synchron
mit dem vom Menschen ausgestoßenen CO2 und
Methan.
Allerdings können dies Partikel Veränderungen
hervorrufen, die bisher noch nicht bedacht
wurden.
Im Moment sieht es so aus, dass sich die Effekte
wie zum Beispiel der Anstieg des Meeresspiegels
dramatisch beschleunigen.
Vielleicht liegt es unter anderem an diesen
Partikeln.
Klimawandel Fakt oder Fiktion Draufklicken
und Raumzeitvlog beantwortet euch die Frage,
also anschauen und abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!